let's try to show that 0.5 is equal to
1/2
we often hear people use these
interchangeably they use them back and
forth maybe someone would say I have a
2.5 pound rat and then someone would say
back to them Wow two and a half pound
rat that's enormous it would get past
thinking about how enormous that rat is
what we can notice is they first said
2.5 and then they changed it to two and
a half they use them interchangeably
because they're equal and that's fine
you can use these back and forth because
they are equal to each other point 5 and
1/2 are equivalent or equal but let's
don't just accept that that's true let's
see let's see if we can prove it let's
try to show that so the first way we can
show it is down here with a number line
we have a number line that goes from 0
to 1 and it's divided into 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 equal pieces so that means each
of these pieces is one of the 10 equal
pieces or 1/10 so looking back at this
decimal up here this 5 is in the tenths
place so we can also say 0.5 is 5 tenths
is another way to read that decimal or
we could say 5 tenths so if this
distance here is 1/10 if we travel
another one we've gone to of the tenth
two of the 10 equal spaces so to get to
5 tenths we're going to travel 1 2 3 4 5
of the tenths and right here we have 5
tenths we could write it as a fraction
or we could write it as a decimal so we
found 5 tenths on this number line but
let's see if that really is the same as
1/2 this distance here from 0 to 1 if we
were to block that off kind of mark it
off this point right here where we said
5 tenths this distance this whole
distance that we travel is this much and
we can see here that this isn't
fact half of the distance between 0 and
1 this is halfway so 0.5 and 1/2 are at
the same point on a number line so
that's one way to show their equivalent
another way we could show that 5/10 and
1/2 are equal is with a fraction model
so here we have a rectangle and let's
try to show one half let's start with
1/2 this time so if we split this
rectangle in half here we try to show
half one out of two equal pieces
so we'll shade one half one of the two
pieces so this is one half and now let's
try to show that this is equal to 5/10
remember this 5 is in the tenths place
so now instead of halves we're going to
divide our rectangle into tenths five
tenths so let's do that
we go so make ten equal pieces four
tenths and we will shade five of them we
want to see five of the tenths so let's
do that one two three four and five here
we've shown five tenths and we can see
that it is equal to one half one half
and five tenths covered the same amount
so they are equal so we've shown two
ways now one half and five tenths worth
the same spot on a number line which
means they're equal and they cover the
same amount of area which is another way
to show they're equal so one half is
definitely equal to 0.5 or five tenths